Speaker 1: We start today with some extraordinarily
sad audio that has been released of a conversation
with Democratic Senator Dianne Feinstein.
This is a really tough story to do because
this is not an age just program in principle.
And this is not about ageism.
This is about competency.
And it appears as though Senator Dianne Feinstein,
back from three months out of the Senate due
to health issues, has no memory of having
been gone for the last three months.
Calls for her to resign are surging again.
And we have to be able to you know, on the
one hand, we have empathy for Dianne Feinstein
and her family and as people, of course.
And we also recognize that.
It is not clear Dianne Feinstein is currently
fit to serve in the United States Senate.
Now, for those of you who will write in and
say, David, Trump wasn't fit to serve and
he was president for four years.
That's not really what this is about.
So we're going to play some audio.
There were reports of this conversation.
We now have the audio.
Senator Dianne Feinstein, back from an absence
of several months while battling shingles,
is interviewed by Benjamin Arrakis of the
Los Angeles Times.
And she appears to have no memory whatsoever
of having been away for those three months.
I mean, how you're feeling.
Speaker 2: Since you are hearing.
Fine.
Yeah.
The problem is the leg.
The leg?
Yeah.
What's wrong with you?
Well, no, nothing.
Nothing saddening or just concern.
Okay.
But why?
Speaker 3: What is the response from your
colleagues being like, what is the well-wishes?
What have you heard?
Speaker 4: What have I heard about what?
Speaker 2: About your return?
How have they felt about, you know.
Speaker 4: Having been gone?
Okay.
You should follow.
Speaker 2: Me.
I haven't been going.
I've been working.
You've been working from home, is what you're
saying?
Oh, I've been here.
I've been voting.
So please either.
Speaker 4: Know or don't know.
Speaker 2: What do you say to Californians?
Like real conversation resigned.
Speaker 1: So at that point, Feinstein whisked
away.
Democratic Congressman Ro Khanna again repeats
his call for Dianne Feinstein to resign after
this incident.
S.F.
Datacom reporting.
Ro Khanna was the first member of Congress
to call for Feinstein's resignation, and he
is echoing that call a day after reporters
had this encounter where she appeared to not
remember that she had been absent for three
months.
This is a really tough situation and it's
it's getting ugly and there really aren't
great options.
And the best option that many are talking
about is that it is Feinstein's family who
should convince her to resign.
Gavin Newsom, the governor of California,
would get to select a replacement.
And I don't remember based on it's in California.
Whether there is or isn't a special election
depends on the number of days until the next
election.
I believe because it's more than six months
until the 2024 election, there would be a
special election, I think, although I may
be wrong, will double check that.
But if it is not the options, according to
the U.S. Constitution, for removing a senator
from office are expulsion or resignation.
And expulsion would be a formal vote with
two thirds of the members of the Senate present
and voting in favor of of removal.
Resignation is, of course, voluntary.
It doesn't require a vote.
It's just up to the senator.
And there is no provision for a recall.
This is a really sad and tough situation.
And as I've said before, Dianne Feinstein
has an incredibly storied career in the Senate.
She is the longest serving Democratic member
of the Senate right now, and I believe the
oldest by by a few months older than Chuck
Grassley.
She'll be 90 in a few weeks.
And this has been going on for years is the
truth.
Okay.
And at some point you have to just say this
is what it is.
Dianne Feinstein reportedly regularly doesn't
remember meeting people that she sees regularly
and works with regularly.
There are all of these examples of Dianne
Feinstein at Senate hearings where she will
read a question off of a piece of paper.
It's not super clear if she totally gets the
question, but after the witness answers, she
asks the exact same question a second time.
This isn't serving anyone.
This isn't serving democracy.
This isn't serving the Democratic Party who's
had judicial nominations from Joe Biden held
up because of Feinstein's absence.
She's on the Judiciary Committee.
So at the end of the day, I don't know what
the mechanism is here, but we have to be able
to look at a situation and assess it for what
it is.
Now, people have been writing to me saying,
David, there should be an upper limit on age
for senators or an upper limit on the number
of years you're allowed to serve or whatever.
Listen, maybe, maybe those things can all
be explored.
Where we are right now is that this is the
situation and growing.
Calls for Feinstein to resign.
The audio is troubling and it's sad and it's
where we are right now